[Music]
[Music]
we can move
to a society in which all babies are
designer
babies rather than these untested
genetic experiments that we have now
[Music]
we won't be able to have children just
as we want them
because we won't know what they would be
like and i
must say i'm very pleased by that we
have
agency and decision making capacity
that's one of our defining
characteristics we use tools
we should not be used by the tools that
we create
hello everybody and welcome to the
matrix
or the miracle babies need mothers
or so we've imagined yet two
breakthroughs in the last couple of
years call this fundamental
assumption into question using only skin
cells as their starting point
researchers in japan in 2017 have grown
egg cells
in the lab while in the netherlands
scientists claim that they are within a
decade
of creating an artificial womb does this
technology make babies
in the lab a credible outcome and
motherhood and birth
potentially unnecessary will it lead to
a dystopian future
profoundly threatening family life and
society as a whole
or shall we welcome the technique as a
means to enable infertile couples and
gay men
to have children and women to avoid the
risks of pregnancy
now with us to discuss these fascinating
questions
are three speakers the first is theodore
dalrymple
he's a cultural critic known for his
opposition to liberal and progressive
trends within western society
his writing has appeared in publications
from the spectator
and the british medical journal to the
times and the city journal
where he is a contributing editor we've
got ganesh taylor with us
she's a training fellow at the francis
crick institute
the london-based biomedical research
center
her research predominantly focuses on
the genetic formation of ovaries and
testes
and last but not least david pierce
who's an eminent figure within the
transhumanist movement
and co-founder of humanity plus an
international organization
which advocates for the technological
advancement of the human species
are babies in a lab credible and
motherhood and birth
potentially unnecessary theodore
i'm skeptical that there are uh happy
outcomes uh that are promised either by
uh political or
social arrangements or by technical
progress
uh we've had plenty of technical
progress and i don't think anyone would
say that despite that progress
we are now living in a perfect
world in fact the national institute on
drug abuse says that it's
that we understand uh drug abuse in a
way that we
have never previously understood it's
made tremendous advances
and it made these claims as there was
a larger increase in the number of
deaths from
drug abuse than ever before in
recent history well tomorrow is
radically
uh opaque to us so we we're not able to
say whether things
would represent progress and i don't
believe that
we can ever have a world in which for
human beings anyway
uh which is explicable uh in
purely uh naturalistic or
material terms though i don't believe
that
there is that there's any human being
without
a material being well there are two
questions whether something
some development is technically possible
and whether
if it is possible it's desirable and the
french writer michelle welbeck who is uh
who makes me seem optimistic uh says
that
uh technically whatever is technically
possible will eventually
be done uh whether it's desirable
or not be that as it may i think that
the
idea of a planned uh society
composed of whoever uh
in which nothing untoward happens in
which everything is uh predictable i
don't believe that we'll ever
uh will ever be in that situation
and we won't be able to have children
just as we want them
because we won't know what they would be
like i am not technically
able to say whether what the premise is
empirically correct but i very much
doubt that it will be
one which will bring universal human
happiness
thank you very much for that theodore
that's really interesting ganesh
what are your thoughts on this okay so
um
i should probably also caveat my
statement with the fact that i'm
obviously not an expert specifically in
artificial uteri
um i study ovarian development and the
cells that are within that namely germ
cells
so i have some modicum of expertise in
that area
so that said the question is um
one is it credible to believe that we
could end up with artificial you try
and um my answer to that is um and
would almost have to be because of my
profession uh yes
um yes because we're already on the path
to
to doing this we've kind of already
committed experiments are already being
done we already have the bio bag that
you know
the uh the proverbial stickers already
been put into the sand or the flag isn't
it not the stick
um so is it credible that we'll end up
with this
um yes highly credible um
[Music]
and obviously it's important to say at
this point however though
that there are um caveats to that so
just because we can have an artificial
womb doesn't mean that that implicitly
says it has to be
a human one it doesn't say automatically
will it be able to house
um fetuses from the age of uh you know
20 weeks up is it from the very
beginning of
of their development and something worth
bearing in mind within this debate
obviously is the fact that um early
human
and early animal development is a very
dynamic process and it looks very
different early early on just after
fertilization first couple of weeks
depending on gestation time
compared to what it looks like in the
later stages um
and that obviously ties into a point
that's already been made by theodore
about abortion
so there's a reason why the abortion
limit is set where it is and it's to do
with
the the ability of the fetus effectively
to be able to survive beyond a certain
point
so is it credible absolutely
is it important to define what
parameters under which we would
uh want it to work if we should want it
to work
um and what it should represent in our
society
is it just a neonatal intensive care
device or is it something that we
actually employ from the moment you
decide to have a baby that's
that's still to be decided which leads
on to the second question
which is um is motherhood um
entirely unnecessary now so uh
or in this imaginary world where a human
artificial
uteri actually exists um and of course
we have to acknowledge at this point
it is completely moot it does not exist
currently but it might yet
come to exist but it's important to to
sort of think about what what the
implications of a technology are before
you develop them even
um mostly because of again a point
that's already been raised
which is that human beings have a
tendency of employing anything that
they've created regardless of whether or
not they should or shouldn't use it
seems thinking tends to go out of the
window in those moments
so um my immediate thought on the
question of motherhood
is um probably uh
more more of an answer as a human being
less of an answer as a scientist but
that's mostly
is motherhood simply carrying a fetus in
your uterus
i mean i would suppose it but it's
absolutely not
anyone who any one of us who looks at
our lives would understand probably that
we've been raised by a lot of people and
that there's much more to motherhood
than just the person who
carried you in their uterus so i think
that that is far too broad a statement
to defend really
obviously not is the answer to that
question however if you
you know granularize it down there might
be certain facets to that which
then do become defunct perhaps if we
create an artificial womb that means
that the day that i decide to have a
child it means that i can simply
do a click and collect job or something
like that then perhaps one stage of my
motherhood might be
completely uh out of the window but um
i just want to end basically by saying i
think the important thing to always
remember with any kind of
discussion about technology is is the
fact that we are human beings
that use tools that's that's one of our
defining characteristics we use tools
we should not be used by the tools that
we create and so i
always implore people to remember that
we have agency
and decision making capacity and that
people have different opinions on what
is right or wrong
or what is worth while doing or what
tools should be used under which
circumstances that was wonderful
um thank you so much very very thorough
response and lots of food for thought i
think as we
launch into the debates but first we
must uh turn to the thoughts of david
pearce our babies in a lab credible
and motherhood and birth potentially
unnecessary
uh thank you um yes uh
they are credible and uh yeah uh highly
likely
um first just uh quite quite a basic
question do we think that it is
ethically permissible to conduct uh
untested genetic experiments creating a
child with
a genetic disorder to continue watching
this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas